this is a production of Cornell
University
as you're honest mentioned I've been
here for five years doing my PhD and
this is sort of the culmination of those
five years and for the last five years
I've been working in looking at biochar
systems specifically at small cook stove
systems in Kenya and more specifically
in this talk I'm going to be talking
about what happens to the carbon and
nitrogen within those systems so just to
give you a brief look at what I been
doing this is how typically a cook stove
system or a household energy system
could look in Kenya where I've been
working where we have a traditional
stove there is a lot of wood gathering
from the trees to combust in an O
three-stone fire which is totally open
air and there is a lot of greenhouse
gases and air pollutants that are
constantly going and being emitted into
the environment however if we were to
introduce biochar cook stove or I might
actually call it a pyrolysis know
throughout the course of the talk this
system might look totally different one
of the main things that this system is
that we are now using biomass residues
or plant residues and these are being
used in this pyrolysis stove which I'll
later go into explaining how it works
and it still inmates greenhouse gases
and air pollutants but those are going
to be a lot less and in this talk I'm
going to be looking at nitrogen and
carbon emissions now you would ask well
where's this feedstock coming well
that's the chapter I'm not talking about
today this is part of the the dynamics
that I look at but I'm not going to be
talking about today so today I'll be
talking about the biochar production
with the stoves and then afterwards once
you have that biochar what happens to
the biochar when you actually want to
use it and put it back into soil and
what I'm going to be specifically
looking at is what happens to that
nitrogen in the plant residues that was
not
admitted into the air but remained in
the biochar so to do this I actually
have a series of things that I did and
we started with the initial residue n
and we pyrolyzed the used plant residues
and I'm going to be looking at the
gashes c and n losses there after i took
the biochar and I characterized it and
um we we realized that there was a
biochar enrichment and and and there was
and we want to look at how why there was
a night a nitrogen enrichment in the
biochar we also look at different parts
of the biochar we actually fractionated
the biochar we extracted some components
from it and so we ended up with some
volatiles or what we call volatiles but
they're Italian extracted volatiles so
take that in mind and then we remained
with also the extracted biotron we
wanted to see how those look and finally
in an incubation experiment I look at
the stability of it I look at what
happens to the carbon and nitrogen how
does the nitrogen actually affect the
carbon stability um so just again a
little bit of the three things that I'm
going to talk about the influence of
small pyrolysis cookstoves systems on on
gaseous c and n emissions the
characterization of the organic nitrogen
and biochar and the nitrogens roll on
biochar stability so moving right along
let's look at what happens when you have
a system where you have introduced a
biochar stove or pyrolysis stove and as
you can see here we have this woman that
I actually did some research with in
Kenya and she's using one of our stoves
to cook and and we are actually
measuring the emissions they're coming
out of the stove so the main thing to
remember here is that when you actually
have the original system 23 fine or the
three storm fire there is carbon and
nitrogen
and generally speaking what happens is
that there's not enough oxygen in this
process to combust fully the carbon and
so what happens is you have a lack of
soak amount to c'mon trick air
incomplete combustion and you have a lot
of carbon monoxide coming out what the
features of the system or the stove
actually affect is the amount of oxygen
the mixing of the oxygen with the gases
and also the temperature of combustion
actually affects those things and then
in nitrogen oxidation there those things
also happen the oxygen mixing and
temperature are part of the the
variables that affect night no emissions
but more specifically we wanted to look
at what happens with the nitrogen in the
biomass what actually is the effect of
the nitrogen of the biomass in the
subsequent emissions that we're going to
see from the stove and in this specific
case what we're looking for is that
still destroy kiama tree but also the
fuel constant the fuel and concentration
and why do we care like what why would
we even care to look at these things
well from from from from a climate
change perspective we all know emissions
are bad you know they affect the
greenhouse gases in the environment but
I think that more importantly there's
actually an aspect to this which is
human health which is at which co
actually leads to 3.5 hour sorry not Co
indoor air pollution actually which
includes co-leads to 3.5 million deaths
worldwide each year and that's actually
a really big deal so if you want to look
at the bigger picture that is why we're
also like trying to see how you can
change the dynamics from combustion
emissions to maybe introducing a
paralysis stove and see what happens and
also Africa in general has twenty
percent global emissions of CO and Knox
and now more importantly as wood stocks
actually diminish in a lot of these
parts
more and more people are using higher
nitrogen content plant residues for
cooking and that actually has also some
implications and emissions so our main
objectives initially were to measure the
overall performance of a pyrolysis cook
stove and compare those to the
international standard organization cook
stove parameters and also to understand
the mechanisms by which co and NO
emissions are formed in the pyrolysis
stove and to do this we designed the
stove which I didn't some originally an
engineer from India did and we've
retaken this this this some design on
and improved it from my Master's on to
my dissertation and mechanical engineers
have worked with us for that but just to
give you a little brief explanation
inside here is actually a pyrolysis
chamber and this is the pyrolysis
chamber right over here where you
actually would put biomass and that
pyrolysis chamber is partially sealed so
it does not see as much it does not
actually have access to as much oxygen
and then in the middle over here we
actually have a combustion chamber which
you still have to feed some wood into
and the the combustion chamber actually
is what generates the initial heat both
for the cooking and also for the
pyrolysis of the biomass however as this
biomass in the pyrolysis chamber starts
to volatilizing the gases come into the
combustion chamber and are ignited so
what happens is you kind of switch over
into using more of the fuel from the
from the volatiles that are coming out
from the pyrolysis chamber and
consequently what happens is you have
both the wood and the volatiles or the
gas from the pyrolysis forming part of
the flame that actually is generating
heat for cooking we measured these
emissions and the performance of the
stove in our lab
just so we could have a standardized way
of comparing our stove to other stoves
in that that are there potentially
available to make biochar as well and
this is our this is our system we have a
hood that was designed I buy some
students and we have the the stove in
there we use two different types of
biomass to represent high and low
nitrogen switchgrass pallets to be the
high nitrogen and hard wood pallets to
be the low nitrogen content and we use
pallets just to keep the uniformity of
the the biomass and not introduced that
as a variable we did a water boiling
test which is sort of a traditional way
of measuring the efficiency of the
performance of stoves and basically what
you do is you boil water that is it but
what you do is while you're boiling
water a specific amount of water you are
actually measuring emissions temperature
fuel use and so on and so forth however
this so performant ly than your regular
combustion stove and we had to actually
to modify the the original test and the
only difference is that generally you
extinguish the the stove halfway once
the the water boils and in this case we
did not in this case we just continued
to change the pots of water till the
pyrolysis had actually been done so like
till all the fuel was used and we were
able to measure real time pyrolysis fuel
loss and fuel consumption and when I say
fuel consumption I'm referring to wood
fuel consumption and we were measuring
with a real time real time instant ain't
our instantaneous um gas emissions with
a gas analyzer hariba to PG 250 and
right into the results so what I'm going
to show you first is what traditionally
everybody shows you
I have my stove in this case it's the
pyrolysis though these are wood or wood
pellets the wood the wp is wood pellets
and these are three metrics that are not
normally used to measure what happens
with overall stove performance
specifically this one has to do with
sort of energy use so it's co grams per
mega joules of dry fuel used co in grams
per minute that's a rate of grams of
amount of CO admitted and that's
actually used as an indicator for health
and then the modified combustion
efficiency which is actually used to
determine whether your stove is actually
combust improperly the products that the
gaseous products so if you have a high
combustion efficiency your stove is
performing fairly well and as you can
see here is this three-stone fire the
pyrolysis stove of our study and then
these are all similar stoves in terms of
what they claim to do so some of them
perform these are more gasifiers but
they do claim to make biochar and they
do tend to operate in similar fashion so
we decided to compare them and the tier
ranking here is the standards the is
still the ISO standards that I talked
about where basically they have set some
standards to see if your stove is
performing properly or not one being a
poor performance and for being the most
optimum performance and for each of
these there might be individual rankings
so you you actually ranked them
individually and Tier one for Co it's
above point ninety seven grams per
minute and tier 4 is less than point 42
grams per minute and as you can see
fortunately enough our stove actually
performs fairly well in that area and it
also when compared to the three stone
fire although it doesn't perform as well
as the stove tech collide which is
actually the highest performing stove
that is out there right now in terms of
admissions and that also can actually
make pyrolysis but you can see that
we're actually in a range that is
favorable for us and that's great that's
actually a really good deal and then as
far as nitrogen because I said I was
going to talk about nitrogen to UM we
want to look at the overall and 0
emissions that we got from the stove and
in this particular case there isn't a
lot of studies that actually look at
nitrogen emissions rno emissions from
stoves because they don't deem them as
important as they are and I don't have
anything to compare immediately but here
what we wanted to show is that as you
have more nitrogen in the fuel so in the
x axis we have nitrogen and in the
content and in the y axis we have an O
you can see that as you have more
nitrogen you have more n o evolution
from the stove and so that was sort of a
given to us that that might happen but
there was a problem we we weren't
satisfied with those results so you tell
people create my stove performance
properly but what does that mean what
does that actually mean for the person
that's using the stove what does that
mean really in the context of how things
are evolving within the stove so then we
looked at answering two more questions
what are the key processes affecting the
formation of CO and NO emissions in the
pyrolysis stove and we hypothesized that
there were the rate of fuel consumption
would consumption the rate of pyrolysis
fuel consumption and also the
temperature and that they would all be
positive cooler correlated with co and a
no emissions and the higher the nitrogen
in plant residues it would lead to more
NO production the other thing that we
wanted to look is well how does
pyrolysis affect the partitioning of N
and so we thought that most of it would
actually be going into the gas and I'm
going to show the results of that so in
order to actually look at the dynamics
of what's happening with the emissions
you actually need to look at the
instantaneous emissions because that's
really what's meaningful here and I'm if
you look at over here in this chart to
the right-hand side we have
in the x-axis and n 0 in grams per
second so the rate of production of
nitrogen oxide you can see that the
higher the nitrogen you have the higher
the Nou have so that sort of tells us
you know the same thing that same
picture as the prior RAF that I showed
you however when you look at Co which
looks so good in that table that we were
looking when you look at the peak levels
of co in this graph this is 3.6 2 grams
per minute at the highest and over here
at the second highest maybe or around
there or the second peak it's 2.1 grams
per minute and what this means is that
we're actually quite higher the the
dynamics of the CEO from evolving from
the stove is actually high and that
actually has implications for exposures
to human health people that are exposed
to that level of CEO at one particular
time it actually can have consequences
on them so these are the things that we
want to look at instantaneous emissions
to be able to remediate later on now we
wanted to also look at what parameters
of the stoves or what parameters of the
chemistry that were happening inside the
stove actually predicted these two
variables so the rate of production of
CO and n 0 and what we actually found
out is that the rate of fuel consumption
of the pyrolysis fuel was actually
predominantly influencing what was
having the two emissions so here
overwhelming overwhelmingly SIA of
pyrolysis rate was actually so fast that
it doesn't allow for proper mixing with
the oxygen and combustion of the co so
then you have a lot of co forming and
wood has some contribution to that as
well and then when you look at the
nitrogen emissions instead of being only
the nitrogen content it's actually the
rate at which the nitrogen is evolving
through the course of pyrolysis that
actually
matters and also the temperature at
which the pyrolysis is happening is is
influencing the rate at which the
nitrogen is coming out of that stove so
that's really important because those
parameters are then later used to go
back and redesign or fix some things at
the stove that we would need to feel we
can address these situations and finally
we wanted to see well so we know that we
have a no coming out of the the stove
but we also want to know what proportion
of that nitrogen that's coming out is
actually a no or other species and these
are the three fuels that i actually used
and i know that i mentioned two before
but we had two of them that were
slightly different in nitrogen of the
hardwoods so we've separated those and
then here we have fraction of the total
nitrogen that when actually into the
stove and so overwhelmingly the majority
of the of the of the nitrogen actually
remains in the char and so about fifty
percent of it remains in the char and
ten percent of it is only a no the only
issue is that we didn't measure all the
nitrogen species that could be coming
out of the out of the stove so this is
the other end species and that also
accounts for about forty percent of the
nitrogen so if we want to know the
overall and nitrogen budget we would
have to go back and measure those but
for this study we were measuring a no
and so moving forward we once we have
this nitrogen in the biochar we want to
see well what does that mean why did it
remain there and to do so we actually
decided to look at the forms of nitrogen
that were actually in the original
biomass in the biochar and look at that
nitrogen and how it was formed with
different pyrolysis temperatures so we
did this using nitrogen k-edge next has
this is troska p and there was some
interesting findings um now why did we
also do this it's because like I said we
we found that a lot of the nitrogen was
remaining in the biochar so why is why
is all that nitrogen remaining and one
of the things is that one of the
theories is that we had is that it's
being incorporated into heterocyclic
item compounds and a lot of people have
also said that that could be true but
not they haven't really been able to
parcel out exactly what kind of nitrogen
and what the formation of that nitrogen
is with temperature so this is like I
said like the this is what led us to to
look at what type of what type of
dynamics was happening with the nitrogen
in the biochar because as temperature
increases we have a kind enrichment of
that nitrogen and there is a tipping
point after 350 in this particular case
we see that the amount of nitrogen in
the biochar is actually diminishing but
there's another interesting thing here
and it's that when you look at the low
nitrogen there is actually a much
steeper enrichment there's a lot larger
enrichment in nitrogen low nitrogen
containing biomass then there would be
if you had high nitrogen containing that
I am as so that actually led to
hypothesizing what could be happening
with the original nitrogen into biomass
and so if we start with some very nicely
easily aliphatic compounds of nitrogen
and then we subjected to higher
temperatures what we start seeing is
that there are either condensation there
is lost of water there is formation of
cyclic rings and so on and so forth as
as carbon is lost nitrogen gets more and
more aromatic or recalcitrant and in
this case it's a little bit different
it's more than removal well it's also
the removal of water and co but oxygen
being removed can
can lead to a aromatic nitrogen or
triple bonds in nitrile which are also
very strong bonds and so in order to
given this we decided to look at the
following questions and we decided to
look at how does pyrolysis temperature
actually affect the different forms of
nitrogen being formed and with
increasing pyrolysis temperature will
lead more two more stable forms of
nitrogen so I've stable I mean aromatic
and we had another question which is can
the amount of nitrogen actually in the
biomass lead to more formation of
heterocycles and the hypothesis being
that increasing amount of nitrogen can
lead to two more and more heterocycl
aromatic nitrogen to do the study I grew
biomass at different levels of nitrogen
so everything was the same except for
nitrogen that we were actually
fertilizing with we did woody biomass a
crop residue and grass and we paralyze
them at three different temperatures 350
500 and 700 and like I mentioned before
I did a solid construction to remove the
with Halloween to remove the condensable
volatiles we went to CLS which was
really cool and I totally geeked out I'm
used this think at Ron over there and we
so this is a nitrogen for x-ray nitrogen
spectroscopy and what you need to take
away from this through the rest of when
I carry really nice talk about my data
is that the energy level of the
absorbing Adam actually decreases or
increases depending on the atoms that
are adjacent to it so whether its carbon
the nitrogen the energy level decreases
if it's oxygen the energy level
increases and that should be sort of the
way that I'm going to be explaining what
happened and so this is one of the many
graphs that I have of my
data but these are maze leaves and these
are low nitrogen I actually had the pair
of each of these which is high nitrogen
but you can't really see a different in
the squiggly lines and what you're going
to see here is all the materials these
are the the plant residues the biochar
and the volatiles and first and foremost
I'm going to talk about the plant
residues and just so you know I didn't
just like make these up I actually
deconvoluted those so I went through a
very rigorous process of two years of
the convoluting my spectra and this is
what I have come out with and what you
need to look at is that in biomass
specifically which we're looking at here
the majority of this biomass it's
actually aromatic five membered rings
whether it's in whether it has one or
two nitrogens and this was sort of
surprising because the majority that
people predicted its amino acids
proteins will guess what amino acids and
proteins have heterocyclic nitrogen so
as finding this actually is not that
surprising but overwhelming the fifty
percent of biomass is actually five
membered rings and probably due to some
amino acids that are a constituents of
the biomass now when we look at the
biochar what you're going to see is that
there has been a shift of energy so this
was the main peak in the biochar this
new biomass this 40 one point 41 and as
you can see there's nothing there
anymore but now we have a new peak at
398 point eighty four and this peak
actually corresponds to highly aromatic
six membered rings and so not only do we
have this new peak but as we move in
increasing temperature which is
happening here we actually have a shift
to a lower energy level so there's more
carbon surrounding that a nitrogen atom
those absorbing atoms most likely so
that was also very interesting and not
only that but we were also
we identified a nitrogen form that
wasn't quite or a nitrogen peak
specifically an energy Liam that wasn't
explained in a literature before so we
are treating that guy has sort of a
little bit different because it hasn't
been described before so it tends to to
follow the trend with biochar and
pyrolysis temperature and then finally
when we look at the volatiles which are
these and these are volatiles and
increasing temperature as well so these
are what we extracted from the original
biochar we see that that 398 peak
doesn't actually exist there however we
actually have this little peek over here
which I did label but it's at 400 point
74 which is actually a cyclic nitrogen
and that's a click nitrogen tends to be
very um this potentially it's very
common for as a byproduct of pyrolysis
volatiles and the literature has been
described as a byproduct for break
breakdowns on volatile so it's actually
a distinctive from the biochar and from
the biomass so that is allowed us to
identify these different components of
the biochar and in like I said in this
case cyclic is one of the one of the
forms of nitrogen that shows up but
overwhelmingly again the aromatic five
ring is what actually predominates in
the end of biomass in the volatiles
sorry so what does that all mean so what
we wanted to look at is who is being
affected or what is being affected with
temperature and here in the in the
x-axis i have temperature and in the
y-axis i have two different functional
groups or what we are calling two
different functional groups in this case
the aromatic sixth ring nitrogen and
that's percent of total that's that one
nitrogen
energy residents model that I told you
that hasn't described and these are all
the other aromatics six membered rings
that functional groups and what we're
seeing is that with increasing
temperature we actually have an a fold
increase of that particular nitrogen
that that we were looking at a six
member ring and in the other case what's
happening is that all the other six
membered rings are actually decreasing
and they decrease by half now we also
wanted to look at we also looked at what
happened with the nitrogen level and
fortunately enough we actually found as
well that as nitrogen content increase
which is in the x axis the total
aromatic or the total heterocycles in
the char actually increase and this
actually made sense because if you have
more nitrogen than you actually can
overcome that activation energy that you
need to make another to make a bond
that's a lot stronger so you satisfy the
easier bonds and then you proceed to
make like a lot harder bonds or advanced
then are more energetically um
there-there require more energy and on
the other hand if you actually have more
nitrogen than easier bonds or nitrogen
bonded to aromatics which are nitrogen
which is out of a cyclic ring then
actually diminish and that also makes
sense because of the same reason you
actually satisfy the amount of nitrogen
that you can actually a nitrogen bonds
that you can make and then thereafter
you cannot make any more so that was
actually really interesting because this
is only described in the lurch or once
prior it was a long time ago so this is
really cool to see you again um so now
finally really quick why do we care
about the form of nitrogen and so that
leads to the last part of my of my
dissertation and it's because we
hypothesized that if you have more
nitrogen
um then maybe the nitrogen is actually
maybe that make some biochar less stable
but is it really and so we all know that
CN is used as a measure of biomass
decomposing but is it actually something
that we can use for biochar as well is
it a metric that's useful and our
hypothesis is that know that it's not it
is not a useful metric to measure the
stability of a car of biochar
specifically we actually looked at what
is the stability of the the char look
like does it increase or decrease with
nitrogen and also do any of these forms
of nitrogen that I just talked about
actually are responsible for comparing
some of the stability to the biochar and
for that I didn't mineralisation study
with biochar only and sand only I took
two of the biochars and the plant
residues without charring and I
incubated those at 30 degrees Celsius
and I measured respiration rates for co2
and nitrogen mineralization for very
liar very long time 200 days other self
and this is what the resulting
cumulative mineralization was in the
upper graph we have just the biomass in
low nitrogen in my night high nitrogen
and when I talk about low nitrogen think
about 0.5% and when I talk about high
nitrogen think about 2% or higher or
1.5% or higher there's about there and
in the lower part we have the biochars
at 350 low and high at 700 low and high
and what we can see is that
overwhelmingly there is a lot more
mineralization of the carbon in the
biomass and a lot less in the biochars
and there are differences between the
biochars in terms of whether you have
more or less nitrogen but when we look
at the total commuter live come you come
miu lative see mineralization of all
these materials what we see is that
while the mineralization as the CN ratio
increases actually decreases for the for
the biomass and it is two sophistical
either significant there are no
differences between the two biochars so
there is actually no meaning or not and
it's not as meaningful to to use CN to
determine the disability of char and
here's what happened with nitrogen
basically nitrogen was immobilized
during the course of our study and that
might have been led not only to the fact
that the nitrogen was in a different
form but we also weren't providing any
other sources of nitrogen so the
nitrogen that was available was
immobilized now this is the final part
and the final part was well what is
comparing stability to the chart other
than the carving what role does nitrogen
actually play in the stability of
biochar so we fractionated the biochar
right so we actually took the the
volatiles which we hypothesized would be
the most easily monaural izybelle
possibly form of nitrogen in the chart
and we took the functional groups of
that group and we correlated those
against the mineralization of the
biochar and side there was any
correlations there was we were able to
predict using the functional groups of
the volatiles 75% of the the
mineralization that occurred in our
biochars and these three groups or
functional groups were responsible or
these three group forms of nitrogen were
responsible or had something to do with
the stability or mineralization in this
case we have the highly aromatic six
membered rings which was negatively
correlated with mineralization and even
though this is an aromatic structure we
are actually looking at the proportion
of this type of nitrogen so the single
bonded nitrogen and so it kind of makes
sense that it would be positively core
related and significant with
mineralisation and then in this case we
just have a nitrogen outside of the
cycle which if we hypothesize well am I
going to go for the easy thing or the
difficult thing to chew on a micro might
actually go for the easier thing so it
also makes sense that it would have been
the nitrogen outside of the ring that
had a positive correlation with
mineralization of the biochar so when we
put this all together what is all
machine like I said when we look at
biochar when we look at biochars we can
no longer look at biochar it by itself
we look me to look at a part as a whole
and we need to look at what happens when
you're making biochar and in this case
figuring out what the parameters that
are affecting the the figuring out the
parameters are affecting the gaseous
emission dynamics it's really important
because then that allows us to go back
to the drawing board and improve in in
designs that are you know ultimately
being used by women in Africa and
currently they are being used in some
households so that's a really big deal
that we need to pay attention that true
where we're really really interested in
reducing CO and a no and retention of
nitrogen in the biochar for maybe
climate impacts but we are also very
interested in doing that to reduce some
impact on human health and when it comes
down to 22 what you do now with the
biochar that you have or what these
farmers do with an edge with a with the
biochar that they have it's really
important to know what happens to that
nitrogen because if you have a farmer
that is going to take a high nitrogen
containing residue and turning into
biochar is it that really worth it it is
locking that nitrogen into these highly
aromatic structures worth it for them
and so that's those are the kind of
things that we need to be thinking about
when we actually think about making
biochar when we actually think about
introducing stoves that are
going to make biochar what what are the
overall implications to the people in
the system to the users in the system
and so you know we know that that that
it changes and the type of nitrogen
stabilizes the carbon but we also want
to know what are the implications for
farmers along the way that actually
using these these materials that's it
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu